-Dude Perfect! Hey, guys.
-How's it going?
-Oh, Jimmy!
-Dude, I'm big fans of you guys.
You guys are amazing.
I want to hear about this
documentary thing.
When is that coming out?
-It's coming out on May 11th.
We're super-excited about it.
It tells our whole
10-year story.
We are super, super pumped.
-I mean, I can't wait to see it,
'cause what you guys have done
is just -- It's amazing.
It's impossible.
How are you guys dealing
with the quarantine?
Everyone -- You guys
hanging in there?
-Yeah, we're doing good.
I think there's been
a massive spike
in at-home trick shots for sure,
so just trying to do that.
You know, I'm not a huge reader,
but just trying to read books.
-No spoiling.
-But, yeah, we're doing good.
We've done some trick shots
with the kids at home,
so we're doing okay.
-What's the trust-shot thing
that you guys were
talking about?
I heard you have a video for me?
-Yeah, we got a video
to show you.
We decided to get our kids
involved, do some trust shots,
kind of a staple from
the trick-shot video.
So we can take a look
at that if you want to.
-Let's take a look.
Here's some trust shots --
Dude Perfect.
-How we feeling, Buster?
-Good.
-Are we ready to do a
trust shot?
-Yeah.
-The first-ever father/son trust
shot in Dude Perfect history?
-Yeah.
-We always do
safety first, right?
-Okay.
-Okay. Okay.
Can you say,
"This is the trust shot"?
-The trust shot.
-We'll subtitle it.
Here we go.
-Hey! We did it!
-Great job. High five?
Thumbs up?
-Love you, daddy.
-I love you too, buddy.
High five. Good job.
-Whoo!
-Let's go!
-Hey, Jimmy.
Hope you're doing great.
For my trust shot, I've decided
to take party hats --
who needs those
during quarantine? --
and, instead,
make red Solo-cup hats.
Not a sponsor.
I've got twins, so we're going
to see how this goes.
Do not worry about
the giraffe on the ground.
He's fine.
Can you wave to Jimmy?
-Hi, Crew!
-Can you wave to Mr. Fallon?
Yeah.
I got my little buddy, Crew.
I'm gonna throw a ball into
the cup on his head.
Hey, Crew, smile for Jimmy.
I'm going to throw a ball and
knock it off his head.
-You want to listen to
"Baby Shark"?
-Got it! Thanks, Jimmy.
-Hey, Jimmy.
What's going on, man?
Babe, you have nothing
to worry about.
Time for a husband-wife
trust shot.
Here we go, babe.
Oh-ho! Hey-yo!
Thanks, Jimmy!
-This is hard.
-No, you're doing great.
-Alright, say "Hi, Jimmy."
-Hi, Jimmy!
-Whoo! We made it!
Clap.
Say "yay!"
-Yay!
-Whoo-hoo!
-Can I watch TV now?
-Yes, you can watch TV now.
High five.
You get to go watch TV.
We're going to
watch "The Tonight Show."
Yippee!
Pound it! Noggin! See ya!
-Nice!
Wow. You got some
really trustworthy kids there.
-Yes.
-Would you ever let your kid
try to shoot one off you?
-There's a reason that we
typically do it the other way,
but I'm down for trying one
the other direction.
We could try that out.
Want to see another round?
Barry, you want to do
a trick shot?
You want to do
a trick shot for Jimmy?
-Yeah.
-Can you say, "Hey, Mr. Jimmy"?
-Hey, Jimmy!
-Hi, buddy!
Nice to see you, man.
-This is Barrett.
-Hi, Barrett.
-Yeah? Okay,
you got to get set up,
and we got to tell Mr. Jimmy
what the trick shot is, okay?
-Okay.
-Alright.
Here, you get -- I got some
balls for you right there.
-Don't hold your breath
on this one, Jimmy.
-Trick shot!
-It's a trust shot.
-It's live.
-Oh!
-Why?
-He's a natural.
-We got a Clayton Kershaw
on our hands.
-That's amazing.
-He's a natural. He's an ace.
-Wow!
-Hey, the future generation
is secure.
-Guys, I got to tell you, I have
like 30 balls in that basket,
'cause I did not see it
going that way.
-Oh, my gosh.
You were awesome, buddy.
That was fantastic.
-I want to see you challenge
a kid or have a --
You get involved in
a trust shot.
-Oh, I -- Oh, no. Uh-oh.
What are you guys doing here?
Oh. You guys?
-Yeah, I like the --
-Would you guys like to do
a trust shot?
Alright, Winnie, Franny,
you go over here.
Alright. Oops.
-Sorry.
-You wanted one, you got one.
Wait. Sorry. We're back.
You think that was funny?
-Yeah.
-That was not funny.
It was not.
-Alright.
Alright, guys, say hi to --
Hold on.
Say hi to everybody.
-Hi.
-Hey, girls.
-Hey!
-Alright.
-Hi!
-So, we don't have any --
-A merry-go-round.
-Alright, alright, alright.
Alright, very good, guys.
Hey, look.
-Hi!
-All right, alright. Ready?
Hit the cup.
-You got to throw it real high.
-Ooh, you're close.
-Hey! All right!
-Good job.
-I did it!
-Good job. Oh, my gosh.
Thank you, guys, for teaching my
kids really cool games.
Congrats on everything, guys.
Congrats on the documentary.
And I can't wait to see
you guys in person.
Keep up the great work.
-Appreciate it.
-Appreciate it, Jimmy.
-Thanks for having us on.